Приводом влаштувати так звані "вибори" стала загибель Олександра Захарченка.
Наприкінці серпня лідера донецьких сепаратистів ліквідували вибухом
в ресторані в самісінькому центрі Донецька.
А кількома місяцями раніше в Луганську відбулась зміна влади – там усунули Ігора Плотницького.
Тож, бойовики оголосили, що 11 листопада населення окупованих районів Донбасу
обере нових "лідерів" та так звані "парламенти".
У Євросоюзі це викликало негативну реакцію.
Будь-які спроби організувати так звані "вибори "не будуть визнані,
бо подібні дії суперечать духу мінських угод.
Влаштовуючи ці заходи, окремі угруповання, яких дуже підтримує Російська Федерація,
намагаються просто зірвати виконання мінських угод.
Вісім країн Євросоюзу, зокрема Німеччина, закликали Росію
скористатися своїм впливом на сепаратистів, щоб не допустити голосування.
Це просто шоу, яке навіть не заслуговує на право називатися "виборами".
Про жодні вибори навіть не йдеться.
"Балотуються" там одні лише промосковські, проросійські кандидати.
Це фарс! І тому це вкрай грубе порушення мінських угод.
У Кремлі стверджують, що вплив Росії на сепаратистів не такий вже й великий.
І водночас, що вибори 11 листопада не суперечать мінським угодам.
У Європі вважають інакше –
адже було домовлено, що голосування організують лише після виконання інших пунктів угоди.
А саме: повного припинення вогню, роззброєння, обміну полоненими, децентралізації та
виведення всіх іноземних збройних формувань, що є прямим натяком на Росію.
Усього цього досі не сталося.
Ці вибори не сприяють пошуку компромісу між обома сторонами,
а значить, спіраль конфронтації буде тільки розкручуватися.
Нові обличчя на чолі сепаратистів ризикують одразу ж опинитися у санкційних списках ЄС.
Хоча потенційний переможець псевдовиборів у Донецьку - Денис Пушилін - вже під санкціями.
Міхаель Ґалер вважає, що слід внести в чорний список не лише переможців,
але й "організаторів" недільного дійства.
Наші компетентні служби, розвідка, повинні з'ясувати, хто ж став організатором.
Самі місцеві на це не здатні, вони не могли обійтися без підтримки людей з Москви.
І ці люди повинні опинитись в "чорному списку", якщо їх там ще немає.
Повідомлення російських ЗМІ про приїзд у Донецьк спостерігачів з 14-ти країн - також відвертий фейк.
Так, наприклад, Франсуа Мо Демея, який ніби-то представляє Францію - навіть не політик,
а оперний співак, якого Франція оголосила в розшук як особу, яка загрожує безпеці країни.